[Music]
Let's look at the
the first part. So, as as I'm moving
like this, do you see he's he's coming
in and I'm going to start this rotating
and I keep him going. Okay. Now, you see
this hand,
you can't do it here. You have to get on
the other side of it. So, you have to
enter and turn. Now, the arm is in this
in the right place.
That's what keeps the fight rotating. So
I go past
there. Boom. And the grips on the other
side. So I don't want to enter here. I
have to go around it. Here it is right
here.
Now every once in a while
they will
bend their wrist already prematurely.
Okay, don't get confused. That doesn't
mean you were doing the wrong thing.
So I'm going around
and he bent his wrist like he's
over here and he won't have it so much.
Just find his center
at the bottom.
The point is don't contest.
90°
always finding
a center.
Okay.
So as the uk when I neither resist or or
assist then I accept. Okay. So I'm for
prescription I have to push lock my
center. He goes go ahead and I move
>> to keep that. Okay.
Same thing for prescription
lock. He moves. I'm not moving yet. I'm
not turning it over. He goes, I accept
what you think is going to happen is not
going to happen if I move.
>> Okay.
But if you are in afraid of the pain,
you're going to tense and this is going
to hurt.
>> But if you go, what does he want to do?
He wants my elbow to go. So, I let my
elbow go till it takes my balance and
I'll fall.
>> Come on, let's go.
just disappears, right? Okay.